à bord chaque centimètre carré est
optimisé indispensable lorsqu'il s'agit
de stocker 50 jours de vivre pour 80
bons hommes c'est donc au bout de sa
couchette que le commis range les
centaines de kilos de farine nécessaires
à la fabrication quotidienne du pain
chaque jour il joue avec ses cartons une
partie de térice assez
[Musique]
périlleuse tout petit je rêvais d'aider
les autres sauver secourir
protég finalement je suis journaliste et
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ces femmes ordinaires
qui exercent des métiers hors du
commun me voici au beau milieu de la
Méditerranée à bord d'un sous-marin
nucléaire d'attaque de la marine
françaiseou les forces sousmarines
françaises 3500 hommes à peine 10%
effectifs de la
marine top un bateau commandant il sait
pas qu'on le regarde
lui il m'intrigue ces hommes qui passent
6 mois par an sous l'eau coupé du monde
et de leurs
proches je pense qu'il faut que je
m'arrête maintenant parce que après mon
épouse me comprendra pas alors je vais
passer 6 jours et 6 nuits avec eux à
bord du sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque
le Casabianca
[Musique]
tout commence au port militaire de
Toulon c'est ici que se concentre la
majeure partie des forces naval
français quelques semaines avant le
départ je demande à Damien le commandant
en second du Casabianca de m'emmener en
cale sèche où la bête s'offre un petit
lifting avant la grande plongée j'ai des
films en tête à la poursuite d'Octobre
Rouge USS Alabama ou encore das Boot des
films de
sous-marins et pour dire vrai je suis
curieux et un peu
inquiet et c'est l'avant ça là on est à
l'avant du marin c'est partie
névralgique puisque ce sont les les
tubes l torpill que l'on voit là de là
sortent nos missiles nos torpilles les
mines toutes les armes que l'on peut
lancer voilà donc c'est un gros
suppositoire en fait un gros
suppositoire de 3000 tonnes 70 m de long
70 personnes à bord une chaufferie
nucléaire des armes donc tout ça c'est
compacté des vivres pour pouvoir durer
le le plus longtemps possible en
mer et avec tout ça on naque pendant 4
mois
ici une sacrée besole quoi on a
l'avantage avec nos nos propulsions
nucléaires de pouvoir avir une allonge
illimitée une endurance illimitée on pe
illimité c'est illimité en fait en
théorie voilà ce qui nous limite c'est
c'est notre capacité nous à à durer et
nos vivres pour pouvoir donc il faut il
faut que ponctuellement on aille on
aille recompléter les vivres mais le
sous-marin lui peut peut durer peut
durer très longtemps à la mer et aller
très loin très
vite à l'arrière il y a un secret sur
sur l'éliss c'est ça un peu l'arrière
c'est notre c'est notre signature donc
l'élce on la montre pas c'est notre on
peut pas y aller par le bruit que fait
l'hélice on peut être capable de
déterminer de quel type de bateau il
s'agit et en plus du type on est capable
de dire parfois quel sous-marin quel
sous-marin de quel sous-marin il s'agit
de quel bâtiment de surface il s'agit ce
genre de
chose on est maintenant à 48h du départ
l'arsenal est une ruche tout doucement
juste de faireçon ce que ça
passe le Casabianca quitte le bassin
tiré par deux remorqueurs de la marine
pour rejoindre son quai de chargement
pour la corvée des vivres tout
l'équipage est mobilisé les camions sont
déchargés carton par carton et embarqués
par le sas le plus large du bateau un
trou d'à peine 1 m de diamètre c'est par
là que tout ou presque entre et sort du
Casabianca à l'avant du bateau on vient
de livrer l'armement du sous-marin des
torpilles pour attaquer et détruire les
navires
ennemis et des missiles pour les cibles
en surface les fameux
[Musique]
exo
le jour du grand départ comme tous les
membres d'équipage je suis convoqué pour
la peine bienvenue bon on y est on y est
ça fait plusieurs semaines que
l'équipage s'entraîne au large des côtes
de toulom comme moi ils sont tous
impatients de prendre la
mer à l'appel de votre nom vous répondez
présent et vous ralliez le
bord capitaine de
corvette nous sommes à peu plus de 70
hommes embarqu
don une dizaine pour la première fois
moyen d'âge 28 ans auune femme je serai
le doyen à bord
monsieur
présent on est pour Poulin
plus voici donc ma nouvelle maison dans
quelques secondes je vais découvrir
l'intérieur d'un sous-marin la France en
possède si comme celui-là c'est pour moi
la surprise est totale vous Prz c'est
cool de tranche bravo diffusion générale
signaux d'alerte et de rappel au postees
de combat bien fonctionné si de
l'extérieur la coque est imposante à
l'intérieur tout est minuscule 6 jours
dans cette boîte de conserve sacré
aventure c'est
bon montrez-moi ma couchette allez ma
chambre les meilleures couchettes sont
attribué en priorité au plus ancien et
comme je suis un petit nouveau je dois
m'attendre au pire
mais c'est encore pire que ce que
j'imaginais on m'installe à l'avant
juste derrière les
tub voilà dans la tranche la tranche
armeation dies arme c'estàd c'estàd
entre des dormir entre des torpilles et
des missiles je vais dormir entre les
torpill etil voici votre il a carrément
écrit exo 7 là ah ou ça un missile ex un
missile audessus et voici votre lit ici
donc vous avez une torpille en
[Rires]
dessous et ça c'est mon pr pour mettre
mon sac ti exactement ah ben c'est pas
mal appelle les Rance donc les supports
d'armes qui sont pas occupés servent de
de lit supplémentaire on y est bien il
fait frais
ah on va s'éclater
làdedans à vous rentrez à PL ventre et
puis après vousç vousavez pas la place
de vous retourner donc faut choisir sa
position
ouais voilà faut choisir votre position
on peut se retourner quand même
bon et ben écoute hein c'est intime on
ver il fait très frais on y est bien il
fait frais c'est l'endroit le plus
silencieux plus fra du bate oua à bord
l'environnement est hostile tout était
triquéain c'est
pas comment font les gars pour passer 3
mois enfermer là-dedans alors que j'ai
déjà envie de sortir pour prendre un en
bol
[Musique]
d'airation embarcation GFM de sous-marin
fort éclair donc votre poste pour le
chînalage à 400 m sur mon avant tribord
j'ai ple de truc dans la tête d'abord le
sentiment de vivre un truc super
privilégié donc ça
c'est formidable se dire que on est là
où très peu de gens peuv aller quand
même une petite angoisse parce qu'on est
70 dans cette donnerai liberté de
manœuvre à l'issue de grand moi j'aime
bien avoir ma bulle autour de moi
pouvoir
m'isoler je je suis pas très sociable
tout le temps en tout cas et donc est-ce
que je vais pouvoir faire reconstituer
ma bulle autour de moi ça c'est une
autre
[Musique]
limonade au passage moi qui suis accro
au portable et au réseaux sociaux je
serais coupé du
monde
sur le quai l'homme à la casquette qui
vient d'arriver c'est le commandant du
sous-marin le
pachat il est le dernier à monter à bord
il s'appelle Nicolas lambropoulos il a
40 ans et il commande le Casabianca
depuis 2 ans
bonjour vous êtes bien arrivé super
ouais super c'est des textos c'est quoi
bah oui on envoit des textos des photos
vous savez ce que c'est ouis les
derniers quoi les derniers quoi
[Musique]
derrière nous l'arsenal s'éloigne
lentement et j'apprécie chaque seconde à
l'air libre avant le grand plongeon
comment vais-je supporter cet
enfermement et cette
promiscuité
à côté de moi le pacha lui aussi
apprécie l'instant c'est sa dernière
mission sur le
[Musique]
Casabianca quand Mme 15 ans de
vieé d' je styl motif et
sensible
donc je suisz
nostalgiqueour c parce que là il reste
la mission il reste la mission il reste
3 mois mais c'est vrai c'est la dernière
fois vous quittez tout ouais c'est vrai
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes bientôt paré à plonger il
est temps de s'abriter dans les
entrailles du sous-marin et de refermer
derrière nous la porte étanche notre
unique
rard donc là c'est fermé c'est
fermé fermé y a que ça qui n retiendra
en Teré d'accord lorsqu'on sera à X m
sous l'eau et ben l'eau viendra
au-dessus et c'est notre notre dernière
barrière d'étanchéité
voilà panneau supérieur fermé verrouillé
plus personne à
l'extérieur rapidement après avoir
quitté l'arsenal de Toulon nous
plongeons à 300 m sous le niveau de la
mer
[Musique]
le commandant du Casabianca le pacha a
déjà une petite surprise pour
moi qu'est-ce que c'est ça commandant
qu'on vient de nous porter de l'au de
mer de l'eau de MERIS à p p pression
maximale merci maximum à on est descendu
donc chercher cette eau ça juste pour
vous app le mieux c'est deabir d'un coup
mais après vous faites ce que vous
voulez et ben voilà
F hein benah j'en avais jamais vu d' en
faitne pas puis après on embrille sur le
sur le champagne ouais ah ouai c'est
mieux
VO voilà bienvenue à bord en tout cas
merci à la votre
merci en tout cas pour votre
accueil parmi les 70 hommes d'équipage
plusieurs visages vont devenir
familier Damien le second le bras droit
du Pacha il vient d'être promu
commandant et forme son successeur
HUG à l'arrière du
Casabianca Pascal instrumentiste sur le
réacteur nucléaire fils de marigner mon
r àord Je suis instrumentiste arrière je
fais des rondes des relevés tous les
jours et je m'assure du bon
fonctionnement de la chaufferie
nucléaire
embarqué et enfin Bryan passionné de
littérature en charge du compartiment
auxiliaire 2 dans les entrailles du
bateau en fait ce compartiment c'est
assez étrange parce que vous allez avoir
des heures de calme et pendant une
vtaine de minutes une intense
accélération du temps d'accord et que ce
soit pour l'esprit pour le physique
c'est déroutant on peut s'y perdre
rapidement
[Musique]
quoi à bord du Casabianca ce qui est
nucléaire c'est la propulsion le moteur
les armes elles sont conventionnelles
mais à quoi servent de tels engins
puisque la France n'a pas coulé de
navire depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
je comprends vite qu'il servent d'abord
à montrer nos gros bras et témoignent de
la puissance militaire de la
France servent aussi à observer à
écouter à faire du renseignement c'est
ce que le Casabianca a fait par exemple
lors du conflit libien en
2011 j'ai deux ou trois questions à
poser au
Pacha commandant c'est donc là chez vous
ouais voilà ma chambre la plus grande du
bateau la plus grande du bateau la plus
confortable solire vous savez votre
privilège ah oui parce que ça fait 15
ans que je suis au forcemine donc j'ai
dormi un peu partout dans le bateau ah
oui voilà donc vous connaissez les
autres je connais les autres P
exactement en terme de renseignement que
peut faire un bateau comme celui-là euh
au large d'un pays quel qu'il soit entre
Misrata et Bazi vous avez un ce qu'on
appelle le golf de CIRT d'accord qui
était fermé parce que Kaddafi a
considéré que ce golf de CT était ses
eau intérieures ces eau nationales or
personne ne reconnaissait ça on les
reconnaissait pas mais on y allait pas
non plus pas provoquer et cetera voilà
le sous-marin c'est un outil qui peut
aller dans vous pouvez aller sans sans
gêne dans ce goldlf de CIRT pour sans
provoquer particulièrement parce que ça
ne se voit pas donc
est plus proche des côtes observer ce
qui se passait donc c'est bien la Libye
enfin à un moment donné dans une
carrière comme la vôtre ça rend concret
tout ce pourquoi vous vous êtes préparé
alors moi j'aime pas trop cette façon de
voir les choses parce que je dire on n
pas là pour
euh enfin je on n pas là pour prendre du
plaisir à euh
mener un combat contre quelqu'un c'est
pas un achèvement un aboutissement de
non c'est bien de voir un jour que tout
ce pour quoi on se prépare ça un sens
concret mais en face si vous voulez en
Libye le sens concret c'est quand même
des gens qui se tuent quoi les uns les
autres c'est ça le sens concret donc on
do pas s'en réjouir bah c'est difficile
non enfin moi je un peu de mal à me
réjouir surprenant ce Pacha à peine 40
ans est déjà à la tête d'un sous-marin
nucléaire je m'étais imaginé Musclor et
je découvre un homme posé philosophe et
très
[Musique]
humain on m'a raconté là que vous avez
écrit à toutes les femme de de votre
équipage avant de partir pour leur dire
s'il y a un problème appelez ma femme et
vous Luiz donner le numéro de téléphone
de votre femme en leur disant voilà et
ma femme me dira j'espère je sais pas ce
qu'en pense mais il que savoir que il y
a autre chose qu'un lien institutionnel
possible quand quand
quand on est pas là il y a quelque chose
entre femmes pe se comprendre qui existe
qui est possible en tout cas qui est
ouvert je pense que c'est
r
plus tout ça prve que la Royale c'est
famille
pour Mar c'est une vra
[Musique]
famille
une vraie famille d'accord mais un peu
sparciette avec ses invités j'aurais
bien troqu ma couchette moi contre celle
du
[Musique]
pachaous les c'estàd quand fait V en
fait qui sont comme ça quand vous AZ en
il toujours
[Musique]
place
va falloir beaucoup de force de
conviction pour dormir là quandme je
finis par dormir bercé par le
ronronnement des
sfleuris c'est ma deuxè journée
d'enfermement il en reste encore
[Musique]
4 oh on a plus 20
ans
[Musique]
partout je commence à prendre mes
marques ici les quartiers habitables
n'occupent qu'une toute petite partie du
bâtiment vous avez donc la cafétéria et
la cuisine au niveau supérieur le carré
des officiers et leur cabine au bout du
couloir le poste de pilotage et le
centre opérationnel qui analyse les
sonards ce matin il y a de l'agitation
le Casabianca s'apprête à reprendre la
vue au périscopeelle hauteur est-ce que
vous
avez là à 25
25 il faut qu'on soit à peu près 16 m m
condition de vis sont pas très bonnes
atttion bien pointé sur le
36 top un
bateau dans
l'eau un seul bâtiment à la
vue à droite 20 venir au
180 vous avez vu là parfait donc en fait
on prend une photo pour rester un
minimum oui voilà donc là on approche on
s'approche on s'approche et puis quand
après on va essayer de prendre une
photo lire son nom et on s'est sûr c'est
bien lui CELI les informations qu'il a
transmisér ça c'est extraordinaire tout
près d'un bateau qui peut être un bateau
de guerre bateau de commerce jus
combiener B on peut s'approcher très
proche 1000 m par exemple 1000 m ça fait
1 km ça para loin 1 km mais 1 km sur un
bateau qui font 300 m de long qui se
déplace c'est très c'est très proche ben
voilà vous pouvez lire son nom vous
pouvez regarder les les gens qui se
déplacent sur son pont déduire combien
ils sont qu'est-ce qu'il F et il VO pas
pas une seule seconde le radar peu pas
accrocher le non cette distance deeçon
on regarde 20 secondes
C c'est extrmement
[Musique]
discret le pacha décide de me faire
plaisir il ordonne deer pour moi le
second périscope le périscope de veille
obser sans être vu drôle de sentiment
commandant il sait pas qu'on le regarde
lui il a aucune
[Musique]
possibilité c'est assz incroyable
imaginez qu'on est au milieu de la
Méditerranée la Mach nucléaire du
casabanca vous ne la verrez pas elle
occupe presque la moitié du bateau mais
la marine refuse qu'on la filme secret
défense pour faire simple la centrale du
casabanca produit de la vapeur que l'on
transforme en électricité qui ensuite
entraîne l'élice avant les années 70 on
utilis du diesel pour produire cette
vapeur aujourd'hui c'est un réacteur
nucléire à la tête de l'installation une
quinzaine d'Atom
plus je vous vous êtes ingénieur
ingénieur de car c'est ça d'accord
atomicien atomicien quel ge- ce que vous
avez 31 ans et vous êtes le patron de la
centrale on nous a remis ça là quand on
est entré sur le bateau donc ça ça
mesure évidemment un film 12 mè voilà
c'est un do ça mesure le rayonnement
atomique si on reçoit des rayons on en
reçoit ici alors ici on en reçoit une
une petite partie ouais on est
susceptible d' recevoir une petite
partie ouais la la législation française
fait en sorte que tout travailleur du
nucléaire doit être contrôlé en
permanence ouais de manière
à à lui admettre un temps de repos si
jamais il a pris une dose supérieure à
la législation ouais vous vous avez pris
des rayons déjà on en prend t qu'est-ce
qui fait que vous choisissez de vous
enterrer dans un sous-marin plutôt que
que d'être à EDF ou chez à r ah bah déjà
c'est la passion de servir dansre pays
en tant que
militaire après c'est la volonté d'
marin quand on notamment dans mon cas
quand on est originaire de Toulon et
troisièmement c'est le le besoin de
découvrir un métier pointu le métier du
sous-marinier et qui per le métier de
l'atomicien P qu' en matière de
nucléaire voilà non parce que je dis
peut-être une bêtise mais vous gagneriez
mieux votre vie chez dans l'armée
française peut-être peut-être c'est même
certain et c'est d'ailleurs un problème
pour la marine qui voit partir vers le
nucléaire civil ses meilleurs atomiciens
au point de manquer régulièrement de
spécialistes pour prendre la mer trait
que tuas
isol très bien mer bon appétit pour
poursuivre mon exploration je dois à
présent m'équiper de lunettes de
protection là où je vais on redoute des
projections hautement
corrosiv
la centrale ventilation ici arrive tout
l'air du bord et repart tout l'air du
bord on capte l'air l'air du bateau et
on le purifie ici une fois que l' est
purifié on le renvoie vers l'ensemble
des compartiments du bateau pour ça on
utilise de usines la première celle-ci
qui nous permet de produire de l'oxygène
comment on fait pour produire de
l'oxygène à 70 m de profondeur alors on
aspire de l'eau de mer qu'on fait
bouillir c'est même procédé que pour
produire de l'eau douce on obtient de
l'eau déminéralisée oui et cet eau
déminéralisée on l'utilise après pour
casser la molécule d'eau on conserve
l'oxygène de la molécule d'eau et
l'hydrogène l'oxène dans l'eau quoi
voilà donc l'eau c'est de l'hydrogène et
de l'oxygène de l'hydrogène H2O voilà
conserve l'oxyenne à bord et on recrache
l'hydrogène vous pouvez rester 35 jours
ou plus oui en total autonomie
d'oxyonomie voilà on mesure exactement
sans remonter sans remonter et ça c'est
l'apport du du nucléaire par rapport au
autres sous-marins classiqu par raort au
sous-marins classiqu c'est justement on
a cette capacité de rester en permanence
de produire tout ce qu'il faut et PUF
notreutomie bate c'est déjà pas mal pass
en s-marin c'est un Lux
supplémentairez une idée de la taille
cette
cuisine 4 m 4
M
c'est lui qui va trouver la trace du
sous-marin c'est lui qui va dire le
sousmarin il est là je pense qu'il faut
je m'arrête maintenant parce que après
mon épous comprendra
[Musique]
pas cela fait de jours que nous avons
qué Toul on a contourné la cor l'Italie
et Casabianca est remonté aujourd'hui à
la surface c'est que nous approchons du
dtro de Messine entre l'Italie et la
Sicile lieu de passage très fréquenté
je fais partie des privilégiés pour
assister au franchissement du détroit
j'ai le droit de monter dans le massif
histoire de prendre un peu l'air
[Musique]
voilà j'avais décidé
d'arrêter ça tient pas l'expérience
[Musique]
déjà passer Messine en bateau c'est déjà
pas mal mais le passer en sou-marin
c'est un lu supplémenta par vous envoyez
trois personnes et on fait descend ça
fait oublier la couchette les deux PES
que je me suis mis sur la couchette là
au-dessus là ici là et un autre ici
qu'on voit pas bien mais qui me fait un
peu mal là celui-là là celui-là il me
fait un peu mal si la marine nous a
autorisé à embarquer c'est que le
Casabianca est actuellement en transit
dans une dizaine de jours il sera dans
l'océan Indien théâtre de sa mission
ent-temps bien sûr j'aurais été
débarqué àord l'ambiance est donc
détendue le pacha a même manigancé un
petit bisoutage pour l'infirmier il lui
a fait croire qu'un câble électrique
était suspendu au-dessus de la mer et
qu'à l'aide d'une perche il allait
devoir le soulever
humour de
marin m pilot station m pilot station
[Musique]
CANM
place quel anglais quel anglais
d'étonnant avec leur perche les Bizu
sont prêts à la manœuvre mais il n'y a
évidemment aucun câble accroché au pilon
de Messine il y en avait mais il y a
plus de 20
an une grosception mais a pas de
câble
ARS
[Musique]
pouris
ça s'appelle un bisage pe faire
[Musique]
des à bord chaque centimètre carré est
optimisé indispensable lorsqu'il s'agit
de stocker 50 jours de vivre pour 80
bons hommes c'est donc au bout de sa
couchette que le comi range les
centaines de kilos de farine nécessaires
à la fabrication quotidienne du pain
chaque jour il joue avec ses cartons une
partie de tetrice assez
[Musique]
périlleuse ici tout est bas de plafond
derrière la plonge Cyril n'est pas le
bienvenu avec son
m94 3 mois en mer plié en deux la
videite sous-marinier impose quelques
sacrifices
ah
magnifique des fois qu'on bah bon
appétit hein merci toi tu es plutôt
légume vert qu' la semelle ça non non
non non non non non non alors tiens on
on va essayer de te filer un morceau qui
est pas trop mal quand même celui là
dans la on mange bien ouais ouais ouais
heureusement les petites unités et les
sous-marins bénéficient encore quand
même d'une d'une table qui qui reste
ouais ouais qui reste assez sympa qui
remonte le moral quoi c'est vrai que le
moral des troupes tient beaucoup à ce
qu'il a dans son assiette et là pour le
moment le moral est bon voilà et ça je
peux mettre ça avec extrême modération
c'est voilà effectivement il y a l'Alco
à bord on va pas non plus
diaboliser Arve le mec qui déconne c'est
pas compliqué sa carrière elle est voilà
explosé en 1000 morceaux voilà c'est une
fois une seule voilà même si vous avez
10 ans de carrière derrière vous ah
c'est aussi sec c'est direct
[Musique]
voilà le chef cuistau les hmes l'appelle
Bocuse ou la cuisse sa chambre dans la
marine il faut être un virtuose pour
travailler dans la cuisine du casabanca
car àord les flammes et le feu sont
interdits on cuisine donc tout au four
ou au bain
marie alors comment est-ce qu'on fait en
gros pour fabriquer quand même à
déjeuner à dîner pour combien de
personnes 70 7 77 79 119 personnes tous
fait là oui tous fait là bien organisé à
deux ah oui à deux vous avez une idée de
la taille de de cette cuisine chef pas
loin de 4 m² 4 m²ou mais pas au sol
quand même au sol on est à moins au sol
on est à 1, sur 1,20 quoi ça c'est
étroit et qu'est-ce que c'est ça alors
en fait ça c'est les frigos c'est euh
les frigos vivre vous avez la + 4 toute
la longueur et à gauche vous avez une
autre porte que c'est la 200 c'est le
congelé le congelé donc là c'est plus 4
c'est un frigo oui frigo
vivre ce qui est important à dire c'est
que on certe les officiés on leur salle
à manger et les marins la leuf mais tout
le monde ils sont tous servis pareil à
part is les officiers on les
dritassiette et on le dresse sur plat
mais bon c'est le même repas c'est le
même repas même repas avec le vin qui
change en haut ouais ou en haut les vins
sont fins et en bas on est un peu à la
et au COCA à la
[Musique]
bière dans leur salle à manger le Pacha
et ses officiers disposent d'un maître
d'hôtel l'ambiance est plus feutré et
les couverts sont en
argent tous les vendredi soir c'est
pizza ouais pizza pour pour 77 et le
jeudi on fait repas amélioré voilà ça
ils viennent ça c'est clair les pizzas
les pizzas les spaghettis carbo tout ça
ils adorent des gamins quoi ah ben oui
le 4h tout ça oui c'est fa le reste de
dessert du midi on le donne au 4h ouais
donc voilà et vous vivez avec eux par
ailleurs ah oui oui avec eux ah oui on
est on écrit on est tous les midis et
soir c'est la nourriture elle est pas
bonne ou bonne on le saitouchar
oui ils sont là pour ça il sont là pour
ça c'est quoi vre surnom la cuisse la
cuisse la cuiss et le comis c'est le
comine voilà voilà la cuiss c'est le
comine
ouais à bord il faut faire le de
certaines habitudes par exemple pour
économiser de l'eau on ne tire pas
systématiquement la chasse avec de
toilettes pour près de gugus je ne vous
fais pas un dessin enfin nouvelle
délicatesse je viens de découvrir que
les poubelles de la cuisine sont stock
au pied de ma
couchette dans ces sacs bleus
biodégradabl des déchets organique
masser depuis plusieurs jours
heureusement pour moi ils vont être
évacués
c'est quoi le jus au fond là c'est de
l'eau ah c'est de l'eau ça va j' peur
que le sac a perdu un peu de son oui
c'est le sac de son âme ah oui c'est le
contenu du sac quand
même ça c'est ma couchette là là là où
le sac est posé là
est pas posé la grosse poubelle qui pue
c'est ma
couchette c'est l'autre côté de l'autre
côté la même
m ok ouv la
porte donc là au fond là c'est c'est
l'au qu'on voit c'est la mer alors non
il y a la porte extérieure elle est
étanche ouais et donc effectivement il y
a toujours un peu d'eau d'accord mais
elle sera ouverte que quand on aura
refermé bien entendu VO aura donc là on
rentre C sacs on ferme et on ouvre en
dessous ça TRC donc la porte extérieure
est déverrouillé maintenant vous devez
compter le nombre de tours 37 tours
d'accordz 2 3 4 5 6 37 tours 3/4 ah
c'est du sport pour sortir
les5 26 27 28 29 30 l'air comprimé vient
de chasser les sacs
allezer
fer la porte
[Musique]
cont7 et c'est reparti 37 tours 3/ pour
refermer la porte recharger avec de
nouvelle poubelle et recommencer la
manvre autant de fois que nécessaire je
penseon fa descendre les
poubelles prochaine fois plus
comparjection Pell sousmarin
nucléire
[Musique]
comment dire c'est pas
immédi quand on part plusieurs mois dans
quelques dizaines de mètres Carr à 80
bons hommes il vaut mieux savoir créer
sa bule moi j'en ai besoin maisord
difficile de s'isoler
toute la journée certains transformment
la salle des torpilles ma chambre en
salle de sport pompe traction à défaut
d'un bon
foting les autres jouent au cartes ou à
la console de jeux abord on est coupé du
monde aucun journal télévisé aucune info
sauf une laconique revue de presse
envoyée par la Marine
nationale ici plus de jour plus de nuit
les rythmes physiologiques sont
bouleversés
les horaires ont été repensés pour
vaincre l'ennui 4 He de travail 8 he de
pause 4 He de
travail à bord du sous-marin il existe
un endroit peinard dans la cale là où
travaille l'opérateur de car qui
s'occupe des égout du
[Musique]
sous-marin
bonjour
rencontrer on est où ici ben on est dans
le compartiment auxiliaire 2 c'est un
peu la mine du bateau c'est le
compartiment le plus bas ouais d'accord
et
là ça consiste à surveiller quoi ici que
dans ce compartiment on s'occupe des
poulenes des des poulenes c'est les
toilettes l'équipage ah vous appelez ça
les poulenes les poulenes on app ça les
poules dans la marine vous avez la
pouline arrière on va dire pour tout ce
qui est euh déchets lourds oui donc là
vous avez
un une des toilettes de la CAF et la
toilette les les toilettes officiers qui
viennent ici d'accord et ensuite un une
deuxième capacité ici de 600 L qui va
recevoir le d'accordord donc ça on
remplit jusqu'à ce que ça soit à bord
pas forcément on a à peu près toutes les
12hures on att temp de reprendre la vue
ouais ça se fait à peu près toutes les
12hures ah parce qu'on évacue pas en
profondeur non on essaie de grouper au
maximum ce qu'on appelle les PIGS les
pastilles d'indiscrétion générale quand
on arrive proche de la surface on fait
un maximum de bruit on évacue un maximum
de choses pour être indiscret pendant un
lapse de temps le plus court possible
d'accord donc ça ça se passe pendant les
reprise de
Vuon en surface je traduis c'est
ça qu'est-ce que j'ai vu
là Conrade
Tolstoy du
suicid
j'adore ça c'est ce qui vous permet
c'est le seul moyen de s'échapper un
petit peu ouais parce que voilà passer
passer plus de 80 jours dans un
compartiment où il y a seulement
quelques endroits où pouvez vous tire
debout où le bruit est incessant et où
les occupations sont pas forcément
nombreuses les livres c'est vraiment un
sauve-conduit de l'esprit c'est vraiment
salvateur ouais etclair Morgan ça c'est
la petite touche personnelle des des
trois mecs qui sont de de car dans ce
comp timent d'accord petite décoration
pour égayer un peu l'ensemble madame
Morgane je peux essayer le bien sûr
assez-vous assez-vous il est vieux mais
il est confortable il est vieux mais
confortable pourquoi vous êtes là
pourquoi dans dans les sous-marin d'une
part pour mon par mon éducation ensuite
les
idéaux je pense qu'il faut encore une
petite dose d'idéalisme dans ce monde
pour réaliser ce qu'on ce qu'on fait il
en faut un minimum c'estàd idéos la
France des idéos patriotiques bien sûr
ou bien sûr même si c'est difficile à
avoir maintenant j'en suis tout à fait
conscient même nous on nage en pleine
désillusion en permanence on sait pas
vraiment c'est c'est difficile d'être
idéaliste mais on se force à l'être
sinon il y aurait plus aucun sens à ce
qu'on est en train de faire ouais et la
troisième raison la raison je pense qu'
motiverait tous les jeunes à venir chez
nous c'est l'aventure en général
l'aventure les doses
d'adrénaline des la convivialité et un
type d'amitié qui ne trouveront jamais
dans le monde civil jamais jamais ben
moi en 3 mois dans un sous-marin je me
suis lié d'amitié avec des gens plus que
dans le civil en 10 ans avec d'autres
c'est comme ça quoi mais à vous écoutez
il y a pas d'inconvénients du tout il y
en a des inconvénients il y en a des
inconvénients les inconvénients c'est la
vie de famille qui peut être difficile
moi pour l'instant ça va 21 ans
célibataireou je je gère plutôt bien ma
barque après les conditions physiques
euh notre santé bien sûr on la bousille
un peu quoi à bosser là-dedans euh on
respire de de l'air artificiel des fois
de l'air qui est pas bon on travaille
dans un environnement gras et dangereux
le manque de lumière soil du V c'est
difficile ouais l'environnement
extérieur commence à manquer en général
au bout de 3 semaines et s'isoler c'est
quoi c'est aller se mettre dans dans une
bulle et s'isoler bah c'est par exemple
en étant seul à son poste de car de se
plonger et de lire 5 si livres en une
semaine ou alors tout simplement d'aller
se mettre dans sa banette
et essayer de dormir un peu ou manière
tout est sujets à nostalgie ici tout est
sujets à nostalgie une photo une odeur
quoi que ce soit si ça vous rappelle
chez vous il faut vite l'oublier il faut
passer à autre chose bon content de vous
avoir rencontré dans les entrailles du
bateau en fait le mec le plus
intéressant de ce bateau il est en
dessous merci c'est quoi votre grade
second mtre
second étonnante rencontre après la
marine br B dans
[Musique]
l'édition le Casabianca a été construit
dans les années 80 mais sa conception
est encore plus ancienne i le Flor
forces sousmar a pensé il y a plus de 40
ans à l'époque du
téléphoneadr est donc très mécanique
plus proche du tracteur agricole que
d'une Formule 1 à l'exception des
sonnards devant les
sonnards le sonarman qui est devant là
devant les écrans il écoute tous les
bruits que font les bâtiments et sa
mission autour de nous et sa mission
c'est de détecter tout ce qui passe
autour de nous d'éventuels sous-marins
des bâtiments de commerce des bâtiments
de guerre et ça nous permet d'être sûr
que l'on connaît au mieux toute la
situation qui nous qui nous entoure
alors notamment pour les phases de
remontée c'est notamment pour les de
remé que là actuellement on est sous
l'eau tous les bâtiments passent
auudessus donc aucun bâtiment ne peut
venir nous percuter aucun bâtiment peut
venirous percuter on une immersion de
sécurité qui nous permet d'être m voilà
là on est à 70 m on est bien en dessous
tous les bateaux qui peuvent transiter
dans cette zone on va vous mettre sur un
bâtiment de commerce ce bâtiment de
commerce on perçoit des battements Jez
sur bâtiment de
commceêtes bâtim de comm
6 et là on perçoit des des mouvements de
[Applaudissements]
ple d'accord comment est-ce que vous
savez que c'est un bâtiment de commerce
alors c'est un bâtiment de commerce
parce que il a un bruit particulier ouis
il a aussi un nombre de PES un nombre de
tours Lig d'orbre oui donc le la
rotation de l'ISS en fait qui est
particulier qui est propre à un certain
type de de bâtiment chaque bâtiment a sa
propre ure et ça lui il le sait ça et ça
lui vous vous connaissez tous les les
BRI font les hélices de toutes sortes de
bâtiments
ouais lui il va être capable de de
distinguer des bâtiments de Guer des
sous-marins des bâtiments de
commerce tout ce type de de bateau et
après on fait appel à des oreilles d'or
oui oreilles d'or c'est un c'est un un
veilleur Sonor qui a qualification
supérieure qui a une expérience plus
importante et qui lui est capable de
dire dans tel type euh de classe de
bateau ben c'est tel type de bateau
c'est tel bateau avec précision avec
précision et quand on est au milieu de
l'Atlantique il y a bien des endroits où
il y a pas de bruit du tout alors il y a
des endroits où il y a très peu de bruit
mais s'il y a pas de bruit de navigation
il y a des bruit de faune c'estàd que
vous avez des baleines vous avez des
crevettes vous avez des poissons vous
avez vous connaissez les les animaux
aussi à l'oreille il va vous vous en
faire écouter un qu'est-ce qu'on
a c'est quoi ça ça
queon a il y a du il y a du bruit c'est
pas du bruit humain c'est du bruit
commandant si je dois faire un métier
dans ce bateau c'est celui ouais c'est
celui qui ah ouais ouais ah oui ça
fascine tout ce que vous m'avez montré
ben bon ça colle avec les métiers qu'on
fait c'est quand même un casque sur les
oreill moi ma viille de mon métier c'est
cass sur les lorsquon chasse un
sous-marin on tous les tous les regards
sont concentrés vers vers cet Hommel
Paris que c'est lui qui et l'oreille
dehors et l'oreille deors puisque c'est
lui qui va trouver la trace du
sous-marin c'est lui qui va dire le
Smarin il est
là mon immersion à bord du Casabianca
touche bientôt à sa fin dans 24h je
serai débarqué au large de l'île de
Chypre bientôt le grand A bientôt la
liberté Pascal instrumentiste sur le
réacteur vite également son dernier
voyage tu as combien de décalage ouais
là j'ai qu pas qu pas je contrôle
toujours sur le 5 ça marche sur la
IP2 cela fait 15 ans que ce fils de
sous-marinier a signé dans leseff
sous-marin c'est bon tu
circalé 15 années pendant lesquelles son
engagement a pris le pas sur sa vie de
famille 15 années à appréhender les
départs et les retours à la maison 15
années pour accepter que la vie continue
même quand on n'est pas
là le le moment où tu rentres c'est un
moment délicat parce qu' il faut
réapprendre à vivre avec l'autre tout en
ménageant tout en se ménageant et en ne
se br enfin faut pas braraquer c'est pas
c'est tu arrives pas en terrain conquis
en fait tu arrives justement il faut que
tu naturellement tu réinstaures un
certain équilibre et une certaine
hiérarchie dans le couple tu as ta place
aussi mais ça tu dois le faire
naturellement intelligemment le problème
c'est que c'est quand tu arrives
[Musique]
pas 40 % de l'équipage et donc
célibataire pas facile pour les autres
mariés père de famille de disparaître 6
mois par an
c'est un très lourd tribut à
[Musique]
payer alors mon épouse elle comprend
aujourd'hui ce qui me stimule encore
et mais mais elle trouve que c'est c'est
cher payer voilà elle trouve que avoir
sacrifié tant
d'années c'est cher payé parce que c'est
15 ans c'est 15 ans de vie entre par
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut que je
m'arrête maintenant parce que après mon
épouse ne comprendra pas on comprendra
plus il y a 15 ans j'avais envie de
faire un métier le métier de personne
faisait aujourd'hui j'ai envie de faire
le métier de monsie tout monde voilà
j'aspire la normalité ce qui va
justifier mon départ un peu aussi dans
la marine c'est que voilà j'ai mon fils
il a 6 ans il a besoin de moi
aujourd'hui il me le signifie
textuellement on a besoin de toi cétait
ces derniers mots et et je sens que on a
besoin de moi plus que jamais j'ai servi
ma nation aujourd'hui enfin ces dernièr
ces dernières 15 ans dernières quinzaine
d'années j'ai servi mon ma nation bah
aujourd'hui je dois je dois penser à ma
famille voilà parce qu'ils ont besoin de
moi là là maintenant ils ont besoin et
tu imagines un peu les parties de rollur
que je vais pouvoir faire ça ça va être
bon ça il y a plein de trucs sympas qui
vont attendre tuimagines pas comment je
suis pressé
ça va être
[Musique]
bon un zodiaque de la marine vient
d'accoster il doit me conduire à limasol
sur l'île de Chypre et pour être honnête
je ne suis pas mécontent de quitter le
Casabianca la promiscuité c'est pas mon
truc même si c'était passionnant de
toute façon je n'ai vécu qu'une
croisière de complaisance je n'ai aucune
idée de de l'envers du décor la mission
militaire l'immersion pendant 45 jours
avec la peur d'être repéré par le pays
que l'on est venu
espionner dans 3 mois Pascal sera de
retour auprès de sa famille dans la
région d'Orléan il postulera sans doute
pour travailler dans le nucléaire civil
dans une centrale près de chez
lui dans les entrailles du sous-marin
Bryan a déjà épuisé tout Tolstoy et tout
dostoyevski le garçon est brillant la
marine va l'inciter à évoluer vers
d'autres poes à bord du
Casabianca Nicolas Le Pacha laissera
derrière lui Toul et son escadrille dans
3 ans après un passage par l'école de
guerre il reprendra la mer à la tête
d'un sous-marin nucléaire lanceur
d'engin le monstre porteur de l'arme
atomique
et moi moi je pars vers de nouveaux
horizons demain ailleurs j'ai
rendez-vous avec d'autres hommes et
aussi des femmes au vie ordinaire